adult kids many of them are still living
at home and for some of those who
finally do move out well mom and dad
still pay the bills 59% of parents tell
Pew research that they're paying for
cell phones streaming services and
groceries and some even hand over cash
for their kids mortgages and rent this
all comes at a cost 36% of parents say
that bailing out their kids has hurt
their own personal finances joining me
now Mr Wonderful himself Kevin oer
chairman of a ventures Kevin great to
see you tonight um what's going on
here so this is all about affordability
let me explain exactly what happened pre
pandemic rates interest rates were
practically zero as you recall we go
through the pandemic we have a massive
increase in basic rates so mortgages
went from three and a half to 7 to 8%
affordability got much tougher in rent
and protein and gas and all kinds of
other issues increase with inflation
rates of about
33% but the average wage in America
barely budged it's about 62,000 so
you've got this massive squeeze on a
whole cohort of people who all of a
sudden leave college and say wow is it
ever expensive to live what happened
here well life happened every generation
is looking backwards saying can I do
better than my parents this cohort is in
trouble
because they got whacked by some
hardcore inflation that has not gone
away and Kevin what does this mean for
the belief and capitalism and the
American dream if you think no matter
how hard you work I can't get ahead and
I'm still living with Mom and Dad oh
what what does that mean for the future
belief in our
system our system always survives this
debate goes on from one generation to
another this has been a particularly
tough jolt for this group that gone
through this last three years it's been
a long time since we had this kind of
hyperinflation occur when wages didn't
increase wages went up about 4 and a
half% inflation's up 33% there's where
the squeeze is so affordability is very
tough in rent for example but there's an
old adage and my mother did it to me
when I came out of college she said
Kevin the dead bird under the nest never
learns how to fly I've said this
countless times and I said what does
that mean mom she said I'm done I've
taken care of you from birth the last
call you're out I'm throwing you out go
f go figure it out and luckily I did but
I feel sorry even for my own kids I said
guys you're on your own Big Daddy can't
pay for everything you got to go figure
it out like Kevin someone tweeted uh to
me because I knew you were coming on
tonight on X that their child is single
27 has a decent job in health care lives
alone rent in particular so ridiculous
that I have to help out with car payment
cell phone three years ago I never had
to do that and your tip for the parent
would be just cut them
off yeah my M my wife always sneaks in I
have a I have a daughter like that
almost the same age I say no no net and
my wife just keeps sending her cash what
do I
do well maybe we have to end with no
more streaming services Kevin no more
you know maybe we have to just rent a
car for a while we don't I mean I mean
we all had to figure it out but it's
it's no fun these days Kevin come back
soon great to see you hey Sean Hannah
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else